ON THE STAGE LIKE HE WAS 16.
TOM FOREMAN, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN VAN JONES.
HE WORKED WITH BUILT.
VAN, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I KNOW YOU WERE CLOSE WITH
PRINCE.
THIS MUST HAVE BEEN HORRIBLE
NEWS FOR YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT YOUR FRIEND?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, YOU KNOW,
THE IDEA OF HIM BEING A MUSICIAN
IS IMPORTANT, OBVIOUSLY IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HIM.
BUT WE SPENT, YOU KNOW, AN
INFINITE AMOUNT OF TIME TOGETHER
AND WE RARELY SPOKE ABOUT MUSIC.
HE'S A HUMANITARIAN FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
HE'S NOT THE KIND OF FRIEND THAT
WAS THERE FOR YOU WHEN YOU DON'T
NEED HIM.
BUT IF YOU DO NEED HIM, HE IS
THERE A THOUSAND PERCENT,
WHETHER YOU KNOW HIM OR NOT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE RIGHT NOW WHO
HAVE SOLAR PANELS ON THEIR
HOUSES IN OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA,
THAT PRINCE PAID FOR AND THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW IT.
THERE ARE CHARITIES, PEOPLE IN
HOSTILES RIGHT NOW WHO GET
ANONYMOUS GIFTS.
HE NEVER WANTED ANYBODY TO KNOW
HOW MUCH OF A HUMANITARIAN HE
WAS.
HE'S A JEHOVAH'S WITNESS.
THEY ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO SPEAK
ABOUT THEIR GOOD WORKS BUT THIS
IS A GUY WHO CARED SO MUCH.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT EVERYTHING IN
THE WORLD.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT GREEK
PHILOSOPHY, HE'S TALKING ABOUT
PHILOSOPHIES IN EGYPT AND
HUMANITY.
THE OTHER THING, NOBODY KNOWS
ABOUT HIM, IF HE HAD NOT BEEN A
MUSICIAN AT ALL, HE STILL WOULD
HAVE BEEN FAMOUS AS A STAND-UP
COMEDIAN.
THIS DUDE WAS THE FUNNIEST GUY.
HE WOULD HAVE YOU LIKE LITERALLY
GOING TO PEE YOUR PANTS.
UNBELIEVABLE ALL-AROUND HUMAN
BEING.
NOT JUST A MUSICIAN AT EVERY
CONCEIVABLE LEVEL.
>> VAN, YOU SPOKE PRETTY
PASSIONATELY ABOUT PRINCE'S
COMMITMENT TO HELP REBUILD THE
DREAM.
HERE'S A CLIP OF YOU AND PRINCE
TALKING ABOUT YOUR CHARITY WORK
ON "THE VIEW."
>> WE ARE BACK WITH PRINCE
JOINED BY TWO FRIENDS TALKING
ABOUT AN EVENT WITH A LASTING
IMPRESSION ON THE WINDY CITY
FROM THE GROUND UP.
FROM "MEN IN BLACK 2," ROSARIO
DAWSON AND FORMER ADVISER TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND AUTHOR, VAN
JONES.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
YOU'VE KNOWN PRINCE FOR 14
YEARS.
>> I HAVE.
>> HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> BLESSINGS.
MANY, MANY BLESSINGS.
>> THAT'S A LITTLE CLIP, VAN,
FROM YOUR APPEARANCE ON "THE
VIEW" WITH PRINCE.
WHAT WAS HE LIKE TO WORK WITH?
BECAUSE YOU WORKED WITH HIM.
>> YEAH, MAN.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE USED TO
CALL IT RIDING THE PURPLE TRAIN
BECAUSE HE WAS SO -- SUCH A
GENIUS AND SO UNPREDICTABLE AND
YOU'RE WORKING WITH HIM AND
HE'LL PULL THESE LITTLE TRICKS
AND SAY, I'M NOT GOING TO DO
THAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT AND
THEN HE'LL GO ON STAGE AND DO
EVERYTHING YOU WANT HIM TO DO
AND MORE AND HE JUST ALWAYS HAD
THIS WAY OF GETTING THE BEST OUT
OF PEOPLE.
HE WOULD WORK WITH A VAN AND
WORK THEM AND WORK THEM AND
FINALLY WHEN THEY COULDN'T GET
ANY BETTER HE WOULD SAY, I THINK
IT'S TIME FOR US TO EAT.
AND THAT'S HOW YOU KNEW HE WAS
SATISFIED.
AND EVERYBODY WOULD BE SO HAPPY.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T GET AN
APPLAUSE.
YOU JUST GET, WELL, NOW IT'S
TIME TO EAT.
EVERYBODY IS LIKE, THANK GOD.
I KNOW HE'S GOING TO GIVE ME
NOTES, CRITICISM, YOU KNOW, HE'S
JUST THIS GUY WHO CARES SO MUCH
AND HE USES MUSIC BUT THE SONG
ON THE STAGE WAS JUST A PART OF
THE SONG OF HIS LIFE.
EVERYWHERE HE WENT, HE BROUGHT
THAT GENIUS, THAT EXCELLENT, HE
BROUGHT THAT CARE AND HE BROUGHT
THAT MYSTERY.
I MEAN, I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M
TALKING ABOUT HIM IN THE PAST
TENSE.
>> YEAH, THAT MUST BE AWFUL.
YOU AND I ARE ROUGHLY THE SAME
AGE.
WE'RE IN THE 40s, A LITTLE
YOUNGER THAN PRINCE.
I THINK OF PRINCE ALMOST AS A
POST-RACIAL SINGER IN A WAY
BECAUSE HIS FIRST ALBUM IN 1984,
I WAS 15.
I -- YOU KNOW, THIS WAS THE
'80s.
I DIDN'T THINK OF HIM AS A BLACK
SINGER.
I JUST THOUGHT OF HIM AS AN
AMAZING SINGER.
I KNOW THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WAS SO IMPORTANT TO
HIM.
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE ONE THING
THAT WAS SO IMPORTANT TO HIM.
THE EGYPTIAN PHILOSOPHY AND --
HE BELIEVED IN THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER KIDS SO MUCH AND HE HAD A
DREAM FOR THEM.
HE SAID, I HOPE THAT THEY BECOME
AN ECONOMIC FORCE AND USE THEIR
GENIUS TO START BUSINESSES AND
TO BE CREATIVE AND WHEN HE
DECIDED TO GO TO BALTIMORE, HE
STOOD ON THAT STAGE AND SAID,
WHEN I COME BACK TO BALTIMORE, I
WANT TO STAY AT A HOTEL THAT YOU
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE CREATED.
I WANT TO GO TO A RESTAURANT
THAT YOU YOUNG PEOPLE CREATED.
HE WAS SO YOUNG.
17 YEARS OLD WHEN HE FIRST GOT
STARTED.
HE REALLY BELIEVED THAT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE COULD CHANGE THE
WORLD.
EVERYBODY WAS MARCHING AND
PROTESTING ABOUT TRAYVON MARTIN.
PRINCE SAID, NO.
A BLACK KID WEARING A HOODIE
MIGHT BE SEEN AS A THUG.
A WHITE KID WEARING A HOODIE MAY
BE SEEN AS A SILICON VALLEY
GENIUS.
LET'S TEACH THE KIDS TO BE LIKE
MARK ZUCKERBERG.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS ABOUT HIM
THAT THE WORLD DIDN'T KNOW
BECAUSE OF HIS RELIGION.
HE COULD NOT SPEAK PUBLICLY
ABOUT HIS CONCERN FOR POOR
PEOPLE.
>> HE WAS CLEARLY A DEVOUT
JEHOVAH'S WITNESS.
DO YOU HAVE A FAVORITE MEMORY OF
PRINCE?
>> WELL, I THINK MY FAVORITE
MEMORY WAS THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT PRINCE WAS HE WAS NEVER,
EVER THERE FOR YOU WHEN YOU DID
NOT NEED HIM.
IF YOU WERE FINE, YOU WOULDN'T
HEAR FROM PRINCE.
IF YOU HAD A BAD DAY, IF
SOMETHING WENT WRONG, HE WAS
THERE A THOUSAND PERCENT.
AND CELEBRITY AFTER CELEBRITY
AND PERSON AFTER PERSON WILL
TELL YOU THAT.
HE DOESN'T CALL YOU WHEN THINGS
ARE GOING WELL.
HE CALLS YOU WHEN YOU ARE DOWN
ON YOUR LUCK.
WHEN I LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE, IT
WAS SUCH A TOUGH SITUATION.
HE HAD ME COME OVER TO HIS HOUSE
AND HE TOLD ME SOMETHING THAT
CHANGED MY LIFE.
HE SAID, PEOPLE WHO FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE WORST DAYS THAN THIS.
GO TO JERUSALEM, STAY THERE FOR
A COUPLE WEEKS AND PRAY.
HE SAID, AND THEN WHEN YOU COME
BACK, TAKE A BLANK PIECE OF
PAPER AND WRITE DOWN EVERYTHING
YOU THINK SHOULD HAPPEN AND I'LL
HELP YOU MAKE IT HAPPEN.
NOW, I'M AT THE BOTTOM.
I'M LIKE MR. TOXIC.
NOBODY IN D.C. WILL EVEN LOOK ME
IN THE EYE AND HERE'S PRINCE.
I'M NOBODY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T LOVE ME.
AND, YOU KNOW, HERE HE IS
SAYING, LOOK, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A FUTURE AND, AS A MATTER
OF FACT, GO PRAY.
WHEN YOU COME BACK, WRITE ON A
BLANK PIECE OF PAPER ANYTHING
YOU THINK SHOULD HAPPEN IN
AMERICA AND I WILL HELP YOU DO
IT.
AND HE DID.
SO THIS IS A MAN SO MUCH MORE
THAN HIS MUSIC.
THE MUSIC IS AN EXPRESSION OF A
GENIUS THAT IS SO DEEP AND SO
PRO FOUND THAT ONLY MUSIC COULD
CAPTURE IT AND EXPRESS IT.
IT'S SO MUCH MORE THAN THE
MUSIC.
SO MUCH MORE.
>> VAN